This lecture is about the web search.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about one of the most important
applications of text retrieval: web
search engines.
So let's first look at the some general
challenges and opportunities in web
search.
Now, many information retrieval
algorithms had been developed before
the web was born, so when the web was
born, it created the best opportunity
to apply those algorithms to major
application problem that everyone would
care about.
So naturally there had to be some
further extensions of the classical
search algorithms.
To address some new challenges
encountered in web search.
So here are some general challenges.
Firstly, there is a scalability
challenge.
How to handle the size of the web an
ensure completeness of coverage of all
the information.
How to serve many users quickly and by
answering all their queries?
So that's one major challenge
before the web was born, the scale of
search was relatively small.
The second problem is that this low
quality information and there are often
spams.
The third challenge is dynamics of the
web.
The new pages are constantly created
and some pages may be updated very
quickly, so it makes it harder to
keep the index fresh so these are some
of the challenges that we have to solve
in order to build a high quality web
search engine.
On the other hand, there are also some
interesting opportunities that we can
leverage to improve search results.
There are many additional heuristics.
For example, using links that we can
leverage to improve scoring.
Now the algorithm that we talked about,
such as a vector space model are general
algorithms.
And there can be applied to any search
applications, so that's the advantage.
On the other hand, they also don't take
advantage of special characteristics of
pages or documents in the specific
applications such as web search.
Web pages are linked with each other,
so obviously the link information is
something that we can also leverage.
So because of these challenges and
opportunities, there are new techniques
that have been developed for web search
or due to the need for web search.
One is parallel indexing and searching
and this is to address the issue of
scalability.
In particular, Googles's imagine of
MapReduce is very influential and has
been very helpful in that
Aspect.
Second, there are techniques that are
developed for addressing the problem of
spams.
So spam detection we have to prevent
those spam pages from being ranked
high.
And there are also techniques to
achieve robust ranking, and we're going
to use a lot of signals to rank pages
so that it's not easy to spam the
search engine with a particular trick.
And the third line of techniques is
link analysis.
And these are techniques that can allow
us to improve search results by
leveraging extra information.
And in general, in web search we're
going to use multiple features for
ranking, not just a link analysis, but
also exploit in all kinds of
clues, like the layout of web pages
or anchor text that describes a link to
another page.
So here's a picture showing the basic
search engine technology is.
Basically this is the web on the left,
and then user on the right side, and
we're going to help this user to
get the access for the web information
and the first component is the crawler.
That would crawl pages.
And then the second component is
indexer that would take these pages
and create a inverted index.
The third component that is a retriever
that would use inverted index to answer
users query by talking to the users
browser and then the search results
will be given to the user and then the
browser would show those results and to
allow the user to interact with the web
so we are gonna talk about each of these
components.
First we're going to talk about the
crawler.
Also called a spider or software robot
that would do something like a crawling
pages on the web.
To build a toy crawler is relatively
easy 'cause you just need to start with
a set of seed pages and then fetch
pages from the web and pause these
pages or and figure out the new links and
then add them to the priority queue and
then just explore those additional
links.
But to build a real crawler actually is
tricky and there are some complicated
issues that you have to deal with.
So for example, robustness.
What if the server doesn't respond?
What if there's a trap that generates
dynamically generated web pages that
might attract your crawler to keep
crawling the same site and to fetch
dynamically generated pages?
The results with this issue of crawling
courtesy and you don't want to overload
one particular server with many
crawling requests.
You have to respect the robot exclusion
protocol.
You also need to handle different types
of files.
There are images, PDF files, all kinds
of formats on the web.
Ann, you have to also consider UI or
extension, so sometimes those are CGI
script an there are internal references
etc and sometimes you have JavaScripts
on the page that they also create the
challenges and you ideally should also
recognize redundant pages 'cause you
don't have to duplicate the those
pages.
And finally, you may be interested in
the discover hidden urls.
Those are URLs that may not be linked
to any page, but if you truncate the
URL to a shorter path that you might be
able to get some additional pages.
So what are the major crawling
strategies in general?
Breadth first is most common becauses
naturally balance balance is the server
load.
You would not keep probing a particular
server with many requests.
Also, parallel crawling is very natural
because this task is very easy to
parallelize.
And there are some variations of the
crawling task, and one interesting
variation is called focused crawling.
In this case, we're going to crawl just
some pages about a particular topic.
For example, all pages about the
automobiles.
And this is typically going to start
with a query and then you can use the
query to get some results from a major
search engine and then you can start
with those results and gradually crawl
more.
So one challenge in crawling is to find
the new pages that people have created and
people probably are creating new pages
all the time.
And this is very challenging if the new
pages have not been actually linked to
any old page.
If they are, then you can probably find
them by re-crawling the old page.
So these are also some interesting
challenges that have to be solved.
And finally, we might face the scenario
of incremental crawling or repeated
crawling, right?
So your first, let's say if you want to
build a web search engine and you're
the first crawl a lot of data from the
web.
And then but then, once you have
collected all the data and in the
future we just need to crawl the
updated pages.
In general you don't have to re-crawl
everything right?
Or it's not necessary.
So in this case you your goal is to
minimize the resource overhead by using
minimum resources to just still crawl
the updates to pages.
So this is actually very interesting
research question here, and it's still
open research question in that
there aren't many standard
algorithms established yet for doing
this task.
But in general, you can imagine you can
learn from the past experience.
So the two major factors that you have
to consider are first will this page be
updated frequently and do I have to
crawl this page again if the page is a
static page that hasn't been changed
for months, you probably don't have to
re-crawl it everyday.
Because it's unlikely that it
will be changed frequently.
On the other hand, if it's a sports
score page that gets updated very
frequently and you may need to
re-crawl
the maybe even multiple times on the
same day and the other factor to
consider is this page frequently
accessed by users.
If it is, then it means it's a
high utility page and then that's it's
more important to ensure such a page to
be fresh.
Compared with another page that has
never been fetched by any users for a
year, then even though that page has
been changed a lot, then it's probably
not necessary to crawl that page, or at
least it's not as not as urgent as to
maintain the freshness of frequently
accessed page by users.
So to summarize, web search is one of
the most important applications of text
retrieval, and there are some new
challenges, particularly scalability,
efficiency, quality information.
There are also new opportunities,
particularly rich link information and
layout, etc.
A crawler is an essential component of
web search applications.
And in general we can classify two
scenarios.
One is initial crawling and here we
want to have complete crowding.
Of the web.
If you are doing a general search
engine or focused crawling, if you want
to just to target at a certain type of
pages.
And then there is another scenario
that's incremental updating of the
crawled data or incremental crawling.
In this case you need to optimize the
resource.
Try to use minimum resource to get the
needed fresh information.